was there a point you would have gotten
married do you think man I wanted to ya
know Kristen Stewart getting candid
about her former love Robert Pattinson
everything that I've done is felt so
right for me Katie wasn't dodging any
questions when she appeared on the
Howard Stern Show as she opened up about
finding romance with her Twilight
co-star was it so much fun in the
camaraderie I mean not only were you
fallen in love with Rob on the set which
by the way I think is the biggest
mistake an actor can make the 29 year
old actress added that while her and
Pattinson didn't work out she still
thinks of him fondly we were together
for years that was like my first you
know hey love yeah I mean like I was
super in love with my high school
boyfriend but me and Rob were like a
little older and it was just like go
gung but he's a charming guy
rob is a really good guy too I think Rob
considers things a little bit I think he
drives himself a little bit crazier like
as well as I do if she even revealed
that if circumstances were different
there could have been the possibility of
marriage was there a point you would
have gotten married do you think man I
wanted to ya know I mean like I think
I've never hoes you would have been you
would have gotten married I don't know
super duper traditionalist but at the
same time Malika yeah everything I've
ever every relationship I've ever been
in I thought that was it don't worry
he's gonna wake up unless he doesn't the
actors stopped by the radio show to
promote her new flick Charlie's Angels
et caught up with stirred about the
action role where she dished on why it's
something completely different I think
there's really the same kind of sense of
camaraderie and it's fun and kind of
weird like girls when they're together
and hanging out and laughing with each
other are weirdos and we're all
definitely like weirdos together but at
the same time I think it has this kind
of grounded nature that we would need so
it's still funny and we still jump
around and like hit people but it has
like the intention feels kind of like
the mission statement seems strong it
seems like it has a reason
[Music]